[Music]
hi today i'm here to tell you all about
google cloud's transfer appliance an
easy secure and performant way to
physically ship your data to the cloud
transfer appliance was created for
customers needing to transfer large
amounts of data to google cloud
large-scale data transfers done over the
wire require network connections with
sufficient bandwidth and some customers
aren't able to procure or dedicate that
kind of bandwidth without disrupting
their critical business operations when
an online data transfer isn't feasible
preferable or efficient the transfer
appliance is the best way to make a
large data transfer
but how does it work
we ship you an appliance
you upload your data
you ship the appliance back to a google
upload facility
and voila your data is available in
google cloud
the appliance itself is about the size
of a suitcase and is easy to move
exactly where you need it
and transfer appliance comes in two
capacities 40 terabytes and 300
terabytes
and anytime we're talking about moving
large amounts of data security is the
number one priority
this device is tamper resistant and
sealed during shipment and is designed
to protect your data
transfer appliance was designed so that
everything you need is on board the
device itself
when preparing to upload your data to
the appliance you'll connect it to your
network
the on-device display and included setup
guide will walk you through the process
to start
power on the device
configure for your network
begin capturing data
once your transfer is complete the
device is ready to ship back to a google
upload facility and for customers who
prefer to place inside a data center
rack we have a rackable form factor
available that can be placed on a shelf
once we receive it we upload the data
into your cloud storage bucket then wipe
the appliance when we're done
your data is now available in google
cloud
now you can take advantage of our
powerful analytics or machine learning
tools or simply backup your data in case
you need it later
transfer appliance is a great fit for
data collection from researchers vendors
or other sites to google cloud
data replication
take advantage of hybrid architectures
and keep your on-prem infrastructure
while also experimenting with the
powerful data analysis tools google
offers
data migration
move large amounts of existing data to
ultra low cost archival storage
to see if the transfer appliance is
right for you check out cloud.google.com